13 to fight armed groups in the Darfur
region it was later used in crackdowns
on anti-government protests the rapid
support forces led the response to
rallies in Khartoum in June 29 2019 in
which 123 people were killed and
hundreds were injured
last month talks between the part of
military unit and the Army failed to
reach an agreement on when it would be
integrated into the Armed Forces the
rapid support forces say it needs 10
years for the Army wants only two
while joining us now from Khartoum is
Mary Mal Martini Sudan's former foreign
minister give us your reaction to what's
happening
thank you very much
for this interview in this critical time
I am here sitting in my house listening
to the voices of the uh exchange of
farmer listening to the voice of the
airplanes above the Skies of Khartoum
the capital and I really feel very sad
and very angry actually I'm enraged and
I see I I say to both of them shame on
you both of you you have been entrusted
for this great Revolution and uh you
already committed an nonsensical coup
and we came back to our senses as
Sudanese rational people and wise
leaders and you again pledged that you
will deliver back the uh the the the
power to the civilians and now while the
civilian operation the political
operation it is reaching towards its end
they come this eruption of this
nonsensical war that is demonstrates
again the
how these uh two armed men uh regard the
Sudanese people in as very low uh this
war needs that doesn't need to come
because it takes two stupid stubborn
parties to go to work things were
already agreed to be settled by their
look already we have signed a paper of
uh for uh security sector reform it was
first signed by both of them then the
other civilian forces supported their
agreement so uh yes this uh war was not
at all anticipated though we have been
seeing how they have been deploying the
troops from everywhere how they have
been confronting each other in inside
the like the the the neighborhoods of
the civilian people and inside the
capital Khartoum we thought this was
just a show of power or show of force
because they have this ego both of them
around themselves but to take things to
this level and to devastate the security
of the civilians deliberately like they
did both of them this is absolutely
shame on both of them and this is a very
serious failure in the uh political will
and
the devastation now or the the the the
devastation to the civilians uh security
inside their homes and in their their
site is a neighborhood will will will
not go uh unpunished it will not go uh
in pardon this is very serious thing
done deliberately over uh several weeks
and now each of them is claiming that
the other one started the war and
because it is simple of course each one
will deny it but the truth will come
very soon at a very high cost of
Japanese people uh Bloods at very cost
of Sudanese people in security and
feeling of insecurity as very uh High
Cost of defamation of Sudan as as a
country of a of a great Revolution to be
devastated like this really it is
something that is putting me really
personally in Rage and I don't see the
the point because both of them they know
no one can can win Sudanese Armed Forces
is the national Sudanese forces which is
respected by everybody which it is the
uh the the forces that is assigned for
the security of Sudan by the by the
Constitution there have been support
force is initiated unestablished by the
Sudanese armed forces and and actually
by the previous regime but they have
done a great job in in supporting the
revolution
uh we know for the last uh at least uh
12 months there have been huge comeback
of the previous regime uh the National
Congress party the NCP who have been uh
inciting lots of of anger lots of uh
lack of trust amongst and between the
two of them and also amongst the
Sudanese public opinion because they
said and they said that when they are
out of power they will Sudan will will
be devastated and actually they are now
actualizing their promise in this uh uh
also very bad way showing that the NCP
whatever we try to deal with them as
country men and women uh having their
citizenship uh they were not they were
not harassed they were not uh Mom I'd
like to ask you about a point that you
made earlier forgive me for interrupting
you but you raised an interesting point
about the impact that this is going to
have in Sudan Sudan of course is a
country with a struggling economy what
do you think that the impact of this
conflict
even although it lasts only perhaps for
24 hours or even if it's short-lived
what kind of impact is that going to
happen absolutely
the the the the the deployment even
before they have now we stopped the the
the the the the the the air uh uh the
airport and uh they already the Harpoon
is totally disconnected and put into
standstill before that Sudan uh as a as
a promising land or for many resources
as a very important strategic land
connecting the Eastern Africa and the
and the western Africa and and making a
a a a having great uh opportunities in
agriculture and now we are approaching
into the uh the the what we call it the
um the summer season of Agriculture all
that they have really devastated and and
it is needless and it is nonsensical and
now already they uh uh Sudan security uh
uh apparatus they declared uh the rapid
support cost as as the rebel group and
that they are waging uh war against them
and the rapid support for us they are
saying they are defending themselves we
know that they have been uh so many
challenges in that but it was all
addressed and it was all uh within the
reach of of resolution because uh
everybody confesses that Sudanese Armed
Force must be United uh All Therapy
support Force must make uh
input all the river groups who came uh
the the the definition of the uh warring
party uh who came uh through the job
agreement should all married together
because this is a major call for the
revolution it's a major call for us in
this political operation to have a one
National professional Army this is our
whole this is our commitment we
appreciate you being with us in Al
jazeer to forgive me for interrupting
you unfortunately time is against us but
Maria Mark Martin's former foreign
minister mum thank you very much indeed
for being with us